now ladies and gentlemen
please
stand
as i introduce to you
one of the finest human beings to ever
play the game of baseball ladies and
gentlemen welcome board let's hear it
[Music]
it's time now for tonight's ceremonial
first pitch
tonight that honor goes to fernando's
granddaughter tatiana
it's roberto clemente day in major
league baseball the dodgers and
diamondbacks going at it in the third
and final game of this series so for
julio rius it's somewhat fitting on this
fernando von valenzuela bobblehead night
chance for julio to become
the fourth mexican-born pitcher to get
18 or more wins in a season joining
fernando in that group
fastball with the generous outside
corner from a young headlight um eric
bacchus marias will take it and 11 pitch
one two three first first time in just
over a month gracie we've been able to
say this it's meryl kelly yeah it's good
to see him back he's seven and nine but
he's pitched much better than that the
thing i've enjoyed watching him this
year steve is just watched him attack
the strike zone with his assortment of
pitches just showing that there's no
back down in this kid this year players
here and there wearing number 21 or
everyone having a patch on their sleeves
good start for merrell gets the strike
out of max muncie
him up
christian walker calling for it
and a good start for merrell the
mainstay he's back on the bottom
two balls two strikes on young maria
stills and strikes a mile with the hard
stuff
to end the ending his second k
middle two no score
[Music]
texas wanted to get from left center
field at a drop in base
first base runner of the game for the
dodgers one out single from turner
straight to the right
it's going to dunk him
station to station they go
big swing and a big sound but
kind of died out there
after they went down in order in the
first they've loaded them up here in the
second and the hitters gavin lucks
[Applause]
two
two one is right to third they get one
and they
turn two
that's what you needed right there
maria's grounds into the double play but
the dodgers get one
one nothing la after two
strikeouts
third one for julia
looking for a one two three third
breaking ball hitting the ground is
second he's got it with a bounce out
patrol turner
on 11 pitches
but uh it's going to be interesting to
see in which direction they go at
shortstop next year
max muncie takes off and steals the base
is that front foot off the back for a
split second when the tag was on i
wonder if they're going to challenge it
looks like the headsets are coming on
diamondbacks are going to challenge that
safe call in second
i think
equity within a franchise matters and i
would stick with seeger based on the way
he carried them in the postseason last
year but hey that's me
and a nice catch by skates out there
there's no wrong answer i love the
lonnie smith one nothing l.a
he does not weigh it around henry ramos
he is up there hacking marte is at third
rojas at first with two outs
that a fastball and knocks it through in
the left center marte is home here comes
ramos with a two-run base hit and it's
2-1 diamondbacks henry ramos delivers
rojas from second
one two to smith
hooks another one this one's gonna stay
fair and it gets by
a stumble from ramos shut on turner to
get to third and smith's second
second and third nobody out cody
bellendrew had a bloop single his first
time
this will tie the game
turn her into score and it's 2-2
might not look like much but it does an
awful lot first one he sees here
and just like that the badgers lead
again
confident looking smooth 3-2 in the
fourth
gets it up in the air deep to left field
ramos has got it henry ramos hangs on
what a catch
how did he hang on to that one henry
ramos go get it
on roberto clemente day a catch that
would make the great one proud
he strikes out unable to leave it
down move the runner up marias gets his
fourth k
top of the order might be getting ready
to explode
got him swinging with the breaking ball
his fifth
max muncie one for two leads the inning
off
this ball right center field forget
about it 44th of the year for max muncie
for that thing got gone fast that was a
bullet there was a very strong swing of
keeping the barrel on top
turner takes his lead at first as kelly
comes home and will smith
strokes another basic left center field
he's reached all three times turner
makes the turn goes to third and smith
takes advantage taking second
and then it's gonna be it for merrell
his first start in just over a month he
will leave with two outs in the fifth
inning trailing four to two
a little bit of a surprise julio reyes
is done in 76 pitches
two runs over five innings in position
to win this game as he hands it off to
the bullpen and
phil pickford christian has flied out
singled one for two
jumps on a fastball hits it deep to
center field bellinger backing up at the
wall and it's gone
christian walker sends one out of here
that's his eighth and it's a one-run
ball
game frederick third two gone trey
turner
sucks on the ground a second flies up
on with his speed
trey turner
infield rbi hit and the dodgers lead 5-3
kelly jensen looking for the last three
outs of this one dodgers five
diamondbacks three bottom part of the
order coming up 2-2 from jansen strikes
the o2 pitch
[Applause]
you